وسط مخاوف غربيه من هجوم روسي كبير هذا
الربيع على اوكرانيا وصلت اولى دبابات
تشالنجر البريطانيه الى ارض المعركه
للتصدي للقوات الروسيه كما هو معلوم وصول
دبابات شالنجر الى اوكرانيا اعلنت عنه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بعدما انهى جنود
اوكرانيون التدريب في بريطانيا على
استخدام هذه الدبابات المتطوره وهي اربعه
عشر دبابه من طراز تشالنجر 2 تعتبر دبابه
تشالنجر تو اول دبابه بريطانيه الصنع
بالكامل وتعد الدبابه الرئيسيه للجيش
البريطاني وتتميز بالمدرعات المتطوره
والقادره طبعا على الصمود امام الانفجارات
الضخمه في ارض المعركه تشالنجر تو ستساعد
على تغيير قواعد اللعبه في الحرب الدائره
حاليا في اوكرانيا بحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
التليجراف لانها تمتلك احدث انظمه دفاعيه
لمواجهه الصواريخ المضاده للدروع وتتميز
ايضا بانظمه الاتصال الموجوده داخل هذه
الدبابات التي تمكنها من مسح دقيق لارضيات
المعركه وتحديد طبعا الاهداف المعاديه
بدقه متناهيه احدى الميزات الاساسيه
مشاهدينا في دبابه تشالنجر 2 تتمثل بالدرع
المتقدم الذي يوفر لها مستوى عالم من
الحمايه ضد العديد من التهديدات وتحديدا
عندما يتعلق الامر بالعبوات الناسفه
بالضربات الموجهه ومن مسافه قريبه تشالنجر
تو ستشارك في حرب الى جانب دبابات
الالمانيه التي ارسلتها المانيا في وقت
سابق وعدد هذه الدبابات كان كما نعلم 18
دبابه يذكر ان اوكرانيا تمتلك نحو 300
دبابه فقط منها ما تضرر او اصبح خارج
الخدمه منذ بدايه الحرب الدائره مع روسيا
[موسيقى]